Donald Trump is starting a trade war and
you know what he said he would do it
this is actually for once Trump doing
something that he campaigned on doing
Trump announced late last week that he's
going to put in place a 25% tariff on
imported steel and a 10% tariff on
imported aluminum now many people
emailed and said David can you explain
the difference between a tariffs and
attacks they're similar in many ways but
tariffs are specifically on imported
goods and services they're used to make
products to make stuff more expensive to
consumers and the consumers of a lot of
these products are often industry not
individual consumers and the similarity
between the tax and tariffs is that it
increases the eventual sticker price of
the end good or service typically a good
when it comes to goods that would be tat
that would would have a tariffs placed
on them Trump says he might do this as
early as this week he tweeted about it
with Glee and of course with no real
understanding of how this stuff works
saying when a country USA is losing many
billions of dollars on trade with
virtually every country it does business
with trade wars are good and easy to win
example when we are down 100 billion
dollars with a certain country and they
get cute don't trade anymore we win big
it's easy I think the only accurate
thing there is that he identified the
United States of America as a country I
can't find anything else there that
makes any sense and this sort of gets
back fundamentally to issues of free
trade versus protectionism and when we
have that conversation we have to
realize that the way that Trump has been
blaming trade deals for problems in the
American economy manufacturing jobs and
that type of thing it's become a very
convenient scapegoat but it ignores a
lot of realities that that Trump either
is deliberately ignoring or is just
ignorant to of course there have been
many manufacturing jobs that left the
United States but many
jobs also have simply been eliminated by
automation and by robotics without
actually going to another country and as
far as the bringing back of the jobs
that at some point did leave to other
countries a lot of those jobs have since
been automated away by automation or
robotics so when you look at a decision
that's made by Trump like this first of
all it's going to impact products made
with steel and aluminum right consumers
don't buy much steel or aluminum
directly but many of the products we buy
and businesses we engage with do buy
those materials now number two other
countries can also do things as Donald
Trump likes to say in retaliation to
these tariffs other countries including
the European Union which is a group of
countries of course can take steps that
would be terrible for us as a result of
this and in fact the President of the
European Commission jean-claude Juncker
has already said quote if the Americans
impose tariffs on steel and aluminium
then we must treat American products the
same way we will put tariffs on
harley-davidson on Bourbon and on blue
jeans Levi's the Canadian Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau said that the u.s.
putting in place these tariffs would be
absolutely unacceptable China expressed
grave concern that's a quote over the
plans and you also have to consider sort
of how fundamentally backwards the
overarching themes of the administration
are right there's a total refusal to
impose the sanctions that the House and
Senate approved for Russia as a
punishment for things they actually did
and meanwhile Trump is gleeful on
Twitter about implementing what are sort
of de facto sanctions right economic
sanctions in a sense on the European
Union and on Canada which by the way the
largest exporter of steel to the United
States is Canada now there are sort of
two debates here two debates that can be
had one debate generally is free trade
versus protectionism and you've got the
free trade side which says
trade opens markets it reduces prices
for consumers which has some truth to it
and of course there are downsides to
free trade free trade degrades the
rights of workers in many ways it can
have a downward influence on wages it's
arguably terrible for the environment
and in more than one way actually the
protectionism side likes to argue that
tariffs and trade restrictions
restrictions by countries protect those
countries jobs that country's jobs but
that they do raise prices so you keep
jobs but stuff costs more I believe that
as it relates to Trump's tariffs it's
less about free trade versus
protectionism than it is about trade
Wars because as it stands what Trump
will do if indeed he carries carries
these tariffs out start a trade war
right and there's no evidence at all
that trade wars are good for people the
impact of a trade war inevitably is that
you increase prices for US consumers on
a whole bunch of products as well as for
businesses it will lead to a loss of
sales for American businesses because
they are going to be exporting less to
other countries as a result of that
retaliatory effect and then you will see
that those lost contracts for American
companies take a long time to get back
if you do two years of this stuff and
then you cancel it for example you don't
get all those contracts back for
American businesses it actually takes a
long time so what do we ultimately
circle back to well we circle back to
that in 2018
lots of political and economic issues
require collective solutions I've talked
about this before Donald Trump's entire
America first thing aside from being
sort of a reminiscence calling-card of
really horrible movements that use that
same phrase Trump's America first thing
ignores sort of the political realities
of 2018 right the issue of climate
change the idea that an individual
country can solve climate change is
ridiculous you can't have a nationalist
solution to climate change you can have
individual countries working together
or a world solution but pollution
doesn't respect country borders the jet
stream and the way that the tides in the
ocean work aren't going to say oh we're
crossing over into another country's
oceans well no we're not going to do
that so you don't have to worry about
the plastic in our oceans for example
you need collective solutions Trump ran
on acting unilaterally in the interest
of the United States it turns out it's
just incredibly naive and childish in
today's globalized economy like it or
not right whatever your position is it
is naive and childish to pretend or to
argue or assert that an individual
country can sort of unilaterally solve
some of these major problems and this
gets me back once again sucks that we
have to go back to it quite frankly to
the sabotaging of relationships by
Donald Trump and of the reputation of
the United States around the world is
there any possible upside to this the
only upside is that Trump has said he's
going to do this but it's probably
possible that he could be talked out of
it and there's only one possible
indication of that this morning Donald
Trump tweeted we have large trade
deficits with Mexico and Canada NAFTA
which is under renegotiation right now
has been a bad deal for the u.s. a
massive relocation of companies and jobs
tariffs on steel and aluminum will only
come off if new and fair NAFTA agreement
is signed and then he goes on to talk
about Canada so there's a couple ways we
could interpret that one is that Trump
is just generally clueless he tweeted
after Wilbur Ross proposed these tariffs
Trump said he's gonna put the tariffs in
now somebody went back to him and said
hey you know what this is actually gonna
do a lot of damage you may want to just
consider the possibility of not doing it
and Trump has now come up with a new way
he's sort of qualifying the tariffs by
saying if we get a NAFTA renegotiation
that he likes would even understand that
I guess if someone tells him it's a good
renegotiation he would back off of it
but this is not a good direction to go
in and we've seen it not that the stock
market
is the be-all end-all of how the economy
is doing but the fact that the stock
market has been both crashing and
erratically swinging like a yo-yo since
we heard about this on Friday this is
the type of instability that again I
know that in some way some people are
tired of tired of hearing this other
countries I don't have to name any
country other countries generally
benefit from American instability if
they want to be seen as authorities on
democracy or economic powers or the
countries that we should be dealing with
to figure things out so in all ways this
is a bad idea and it's a separate
question from if we were to go back to
the beginning whether we would want to
adopt a policy closer to free trade or
closer to protectionism we have a status
quo and what we have to consider now is
sort of how these pronouncements how
these decisions will impact that status
quo and this is not good
send me your thoughts I'm on Twitter at
Dee Pakman the show is on Twitter at
David Pakman show we've got a lot to
talk about today including Melania Trump
liked one of our videos and it was about
her I'll tell you about that later
today's program is sponsored in part by
Blink 'us the entire idea behind blinka
stand the service they provide is
perfect for me and I assume really great
for a lot of people in our audience too
if you watch this show you know I read a
lot of nonfiction books and blink astiz
an app that takes nonfiction books and
it distills the most important points
and insights from the book down to a
powerful package of information which
can be read or listened to in about 15
minutes on your mobile device or tablet
you can zip through books really quickly
I still think it's great to absorb the
wisdom of books by reading them slowly
and in their entirety deep reading is
what it's called but not everybody I
know I don't have the time to read all
the non-fiction books that I really want
to so for the ones I can't read blink
astiz the next best thing
huge selection for one
low flat rate you get access to
thousands of books you can switch
between text and audio both online and
offline and you also get personalized
recommendations based on books you've
already chosen join over 4 million
people already using bling cos that made
the iTunes best apps of 2017 list it's
free to try but you can also get a 20%
discount on a yearly membership by
visiting blinkers comm slash Pakman if
you're watching on YouTube we've put a
link in the description underneath the
video again that's blink is comm /p a
que ma n